House of the Dragon episode 7 has a
funeral and a wedding and a dragon
flight and a child fight and a fake
murder so what happens and what does it
mean this video has no spoilers for hot
day past episode 7. in the previous
episode Lena valerion died she was the
daughter of Corliss and rainy son the
sister of Lenor the wife of Daemon and
the mother of Baylor and Rayna so the
whole royal family comes to her funeral
on driftmark many of their dragons also
come the book says there were so many
dragons here it was like driftmark was
the new valyria valyria who was the
Great Dragon Lord Empire before its
downfall this Dragon appears to be
aegon's Dragon Sunfire the books say
that Sunfire is the most beautiful and
most magnificent dragon ever with
gleaming golden scales and pale pink
Wing membranes and this Dragon might be
Helena's Dragon dream Fire Dream fire is
one of the bigger older dragons and is
colored pale blue with silvery markings
so we've now seen eight dragons in hot
day Luke and Baylor also have dragons
that we haven't seen yet targaryens
burned their dead with dragon fire but
the valerions historically never had
dragons their power was ships on the sea
so Lena's coffin is laid to rest in the
ocean the showrunner says this ritual is
called the seat of the sea and that
centuries of valerion sarcophagi form
the foundation of the island of high
tide vemond valerion says that the
Merlin King a mermaid God will godliner
in the Eternal Waters house Tully's
funeral rights also speak of an
underwater afterlife and the ironborn
believed that after death they will
party with the Drowned God in his watery
Halls like a wet Valhalla in the books
there are hints that Behind These
Legends of Sea Gods is something more
monstrous and lovecraftian but Lena is
laid to rest and her uncle vemond uses
his speech to make a political point
vamon says that valerion blood runs true
and valerion blood must never thin and
he looks pointedly at rhaenyra's Sons
Jace and Luke because Jace and Luke are
called valerion but they don't really
have Lenor valerion's blood they're
actually Harwin Strong's bastards
vemon's brother Lord carlis wants Luke
to inherit driftmark and be the next
valerion Lord but vemond doesn't want
that instead he mentions Lena's trueborn
daughters Baylor and Rayna they have
valerion blood so vamon seems to want
them to inherit drift Mark not Luke
we've seen vemond and Corliss Clash
before this could be the beginning of a
succession dispute within house valarion
Daemon laughs at vemond for using a
eulogy for petty politics this kind of
BS is exactly why Daemon left caught and
stayed in pentos all those years
callus tells Luke that he'll inherit
driftmark because Jace is heir to the
throne after rhaenyra and Lenor is King
consort but Luke says he doesn't want to
be a Lord because that'll only happen
when more of his family dies these poor
kids are traumatized by the death and
tragedy happening around them but the
adults keep pushing them into politics
and Conflict for the sake of their
Ambitions I don't want to I don't want
it Jace knows the truth he's not Leno's
son he's harwin's bastard so Jay says
that he should get to mourn his father
and grandfather's death at harrenhal but
rhaenyra says they both must hide their
grief for Harwin and pretend that Lenor
is Jace's father or else the valerians
won't support them and as a bars did
Jace's claim to the throne would be
weaker the adult's political schemes
make their kids suffer aemond almost
speaks to Jace but they're separated by
a fire between them representing their
family's burning conflict so amond
hesitates and backs off which is tragic
because if these boys had talked and
connected maybe they wouldn't have had
that terrible fight later on Helena
Targaryen is the daughter of viserys and
Allison and she likes Bugs and saying
mysterious cryptic [ __ ] so Helena says
hand turns Loom spool of green spool of
black dragons of Flesh weaving dragons
of thread the dragons are targaryens and
the spools of thread are viserys's
bloodline the spool of green is
viserys's children with Allison the
spool of black is rhaenyra and her kids
the hand turning the loom might refer to
the hand of the king Otto Hightower
because it was Otto's manipulation that
got Alison with viserys and started the
spool of green blooms and thread in
general can symbolize fate and destiny
like the fates in real mythology who
weave the threads of human Destiny on a
loom it seems that Helena has prophetic
dreams of the future giving her glimpses
of the fabric of human Destiny but her
Visions aren't very helpful when no one
listens to her Helena is now betrothed
to marry her brother aegon incest is
traditional for the targaryens aegon the
Conqueror married his sisters King
joharis married his sister and viserys
and daemon's parents were siblings the
targaryens do this to keep their blood
pure and to keep their dragon writing
genes in the family aegon and Helena's
mother Alison previously seemed
disgusted by Targaryen incest she is a
religious woman and the faith of the
seven considers incest and Abomination
the faith tolerates Targaryen incest
only reluctantly so how does Allison
feel about her children marrying each
other maybe it was viserys's idea and
she just went along with it or maybe
Alison put aside her morality and
supported this marriage because it's
useful politically Alison wants aegon to
inherit the throne and marrying his
sister makes aegon seem more like a
legitimate traditional Targaryen King
someone who will produce Targaryen
Dragon riding heirs aegon was probably
named aegon like aegon the Conqueror for
the same reason to make him seem like a
true king but aside from the name
Ellison's son is not much like aegon the
Conqueror all aegon wants to do is drink
and hit on girls it's the second son
aemond who is more dutiful and more
focused on their family's strength
so Otto Hightower is now hand of the
King again to replace Lionel strong
previously viserys fired Otto because
Otto was manipulative and biased towards
his own family but now he's brought Otto
back maybe under pressure from Alison in
the books viserys considers making
rhaenyra hand of the king but he doesn't
because that might cause conflict
between rhaenyra and Alison so instead
of dealing with this conflict viserys
just does the easy thing and lets Otto
have power despite the fact that Otto
obviously doesn't support viserys's
chosen Heir rhaenyra the old hatred
between Daemon and Otto is not forgotten
Daemon calls Otto a leech so everyone
marinates in their unhappiness and
glares at each other meaningfully Alison
hates rain era rhaenyra wants Daemon
viserys tries to reunite with Daemon and
Daemon pretends that he doesn't need
anyone visera us mistakenly calls Alison
Emma Emma was the name of viserys's
previous wife it seems like viserys's
sickness is affecting his mind which is
disturbing if the king loses his marbles
who will hold this broken family and
this Kingdom together this also shows
that Emma is still on viserys's mind the
actor and writers say that viserys made
rhaenyra Heir as an act of love for Emma
viserys still feels guilty for Emma's
death and sees rhaenyra as The Last
Remnant of the woman he loved and still
loves rhaenys and Corliss mourn their
dead daughter Lena rhaenys says again
that corliss's political Ambitions put
their children in danger to honor Lena
rhaenys wants Lena's daughter Baylor to
inherit driftmark like vemon she doesn't
support Luke getting driftmark because
Luke doesn't have valerion blood but
call us has a different view on Legacy
he says that history does not remember
blood it remembers names Corliss doesn't
care that Luke and Jace aren't really
his grandkids because their names are
still valerion while Baylor's name is
Targaryen Corliss won't back down on his
Ambitions and rhaenys is frustrated
rhaenyra reconnects with her Uncle
Daemon they talk about their
frustrations with their Partners Daemon
didn't quite love Lena and rhaenyra says
Lenor is useless rhaenyra talks about
her sexual desires it was Daemon who
awakened rhaenyra's desire when she was
a teenager Rainier never let go of that
attraction so she kisses Daemon and then
has sex with her uncle on the beach
which is a bad idea for several reasons
like they're just outside a funeral
rhaenyra is married and they will get
sand in all of their crevices but
rhaenyra and Daemon find deep status of
action in putting aside their duties and
politics and lies and just indulging
their true desires meanwhile amond
fulfills his desire he wants a dragon to
fulfill his Birthright as a Targaryen
Prince to get power and freedom and to
stop the other kids from bullying him
with pigs in the books vasera suggests
that amond could claim a dragon egg or a
hatchling on Dragonstone there are also
older dragons like Verma Thor and
silverling available but amond wants
nothing less than the biggest most
powerful Dragon in the world Vega with
her first writer visenya Vega fought in
aegon's Conquest alongside valerion the
black dread and maraxis Vega has burned
and battled all across Westeros most
recently vegar was Lena valerion's
Dragon but with Lena dead Vega is
available again so amond finds vegar
sleeping on the beach according to the
ringerverse podcast a hot D sound
designer said vegar is old lonely and
has IBS and they made a gigantic fart
sound for Vega which sadly HBO did not
use the books say that Vega has become
sleepy in her ancient age and she does
not like being woken up but amond is
brave and as a true Targaryen he has the
Dragon Rider blood that makes it
possible to control dragons it looks
like Vega can smell aemon's Dragon Blood
aemond commands vegar in Valyrian he
says dohiris meaning serve and likiri
meaning be calm he mounts Vega and says
Silvis meaning fly and so amond rides
the greatest Dragon through this guy he
almost falls off a few times you are
meant to chain your belt to the saddle
so that you don't fall off but aemon
survives proves his manhood and bonds
with the most powerful weapon of war in
this world once a rider bonds with a
dragon no one else can control the
dragon until the rider dies so Rayna and
Baylor are angry Vega was their mother's
Dragon so they wanted Rayna to Acclaim
Vega there's no rule that a dragon
Rider's child gets their parents Dragon
like before Elena Vegas rider was Balon
Targaryen but balon's Sons didn't get
Vega Lena took her but it's certainly a
faux pas at least to take Vega on the
night of Lena's funeral Baylor and Reina
wake Jace and Luke and together they
confront aemond in the book Baylor and
Reina aren't present but three-year-old
Joffrey is there and amond shoves Joff
into a pile of dragon poop amond is full
of adrenaline and arrogance drunk with
new power so he insults Rayna then Rayna
and Baylor attack amond he fights back
and it turns into an all-out brawl which
is not surprising because these boys
were trained to fight and to see each
other as enemies the adults taught them
that bastardi is a shameful Deadly
Secret so when amond calls Jace and Luke
bastards and threatens the brothers Luke
slashes aemon's face taking his eye in
the previous episode Helena said that to
get a dragon amond would have to close
an eye she saw the future probably in
her dreams amond later says that it's
okay he lost an eye because he gained
the power of Vega in mythology the
sacrifice of an eye can grant Godlike
power
in the aftermath King viserys tries to
make peace Allison decides with amond
rhaenyra sides with her sons and
everybody is pissed off Daemon seems to
enjoy the conflict and Chaos he was
happy to watch them all implode he's a
Lena Daemon I always like the idea that
he sort of leans
Jace and Luke say that amond called them
bastards and rhaenyra says this is high
treason and that amond must be sharply
questioned sharp questioning is a
euphemism for torture in interrogation
so it's pretty extreme for rhaenyra to
demand the torture of an already
mutilated child because that child told
the truth about rhaenyra's infidelity
that is brazen but rhaenyra brings up
these allegations to try and force a
confrontation maybe hoping that King
viserys will publicly side with her not
with Alison aegon says everyone knows
that Jace and Luke are bastards just
look at them it's obvious so the deadly
treasonous truth is spoken and King
viserys fails to resolve it he just
shouts at everyone in general to just be
cool and be friends please with his
empty shirt sleeve flapping in instantly
then he tries to leave as though the
problem is solved but no one is
satisfied the king fails to make Justice
and peace the whole scene is similar to
episode 2 of Game of Thrones when I
Stark fights Joffrey then King Robert
tries and fails to make peace the
Lannisters and Starks just learned to
hate each other more and the King's
failure to make Justice plants the seeds
for war so Alison tries to make her own
Justice she orders Kristen to cut out
Luke's eye to pay the debt of amon's
lost eye Kristen refuses he's not mad
enough to mutilate a prince but Alison
is she takes viserys's Valyrian steel
knife and attacks after a lifetime of
suppressing her emotions of sacrificing
her desires for the sake of others
expectations acting courteous and proper
at all times she finally explodes with
murderous rage Alison says that while
she has always done her Duty rhaenyra
constantly Breaks the Rules with her
bastards and lies flaunting her Freedom
with sex and dragon flight Allison is
bitterly envious that rhaenyra gets to
do what she wants without consequence
and now even escapes Justice for the
mutilation of Allison's son but rhaenyra
says that Alison's righteousness is a
cloak a disguise that Alison acts like
she's better than rhaenyra but really
she's just motivated by Petty envy and
spite the tragedy of this fight is that
rhaenyra and Alison were once best
friends Alison's actor said Allison and
rhaenyra would have been much stronger
together but they were driven apart by
this political system with its
restrictions on women's sexuality and on
bastards and its name demand for one
bloodline to dominate all others it's
cause of the Ambitions of men like Otto
who made Alison marry viserys in the
first place that politics is what drove
rhaenyra and Alison apart that's why
Allison's life sucks but Alison projects
all of her anger at rhaenyra rhaenyra is
cut with the knife and their conflict
draws First Blood the king says he's
done and walks off leaving his daughter
bleeding at his wife's hands leaving his
son mutilated leaving his family divided
the Valyrian steel dagger lies on the
floor this dagger represents the
prophecy of aegon the Conqueror the need
for House Targaryen to be United to save
the world from the white walkers viserys
fails to uphold this sacred
responsibility
rhaenyra stands with Daemon and the
valerians an Alison with her sons and
Kristen rhaenyra later calls Alison's
side the greens and in the books
rhaenyra's side is called the blacks
peace between these sides now seems
impossible Alison feels guilty and
shocked by her violent Outburst rhaenyra
said earlier that Alison isn't capable
of cold murder but Daemon replied that
everyone is capable of depravity Now
Alison finds the depravity within
herself and she's horrified by it but
her father Otto is glad he's happy that
Alison has the determination to win this
ugly game to get aegon on the throne for
their house he's also fine with amond
losing an eye he says it's worth it to
get Vega so Otto's family is spiraling
into violence his daughter assaulting
Royal his grandkid losing body parts and
riding a deadly scaly nuke and Otto
could not be more proud rhaenyra gets
stitched up with thread like aemond is
stitched up with thread this might
represent the green and black thread
that Helena mentioned earlier Lenor
valerion is having a bad time the death
of his sister Elena made lane or think
about his own life and he realizes that
he has failed as a husband to Reign era
and as an adoptive father to Jace Luke
and Joff rhaenyra mentions that she and
Lenor did try to conceive children
together in the book mushroom says that
rhaenyra Leno and Carl had threesomes
together but they failed to make a child
and it is important that rhaenyra and
Lenor tried to produce legitimate
children because that means the rhaenyra
was kind of Justified in making kids
with someone else she needs as and she
couldn't get them from Lenor though it
would have been smarter to have bastard
kids with someone who at least looked
like Lenor rather than with Harwin whose
appearance makes the bastardy obvious
Lenor says he wishes he wasn't born gay
but rhaenyra says that Leno is a good
person regardless of how Society sees
his sexuality right near his sexuality
is scrutinized as well and we see how
unfair that is when males like aegon get
to [ __ ] around with no consequence Lenor
takes responsibility for his failures he
says he'll stop seeing his boyfriend
Carl and will instead dedicate himself
to rhaenyra and their family he says
he'll sacrifice his happiness for the
sake of his duty in Game of Thrones
aemon says that love is the death of
Duty so Lenor prepares to give up his
love Alison leaves driftmark and Corliss
and rainy Swatch as Vega their
daughter's dragon and the greatest
weapon in this world leaves their
control in amon's hands Lara strong
slides into Alison's DMS and offers to
do a murder or to get an eyeball for her
or whatever she wants we know that Laris
is capable of anything after he burned
his own family with his fireflies maybe
Laris just wants to please Alison
because he's creepily obsessed with her
or maybe he wants to make this conflict
worse to use chaos to gain power or
maybe he just loves killing but his
offer is like a Faustian pact a deal
with the devil he tempts her with power
but his evil May taint or trap Alison
Alison tells him to not kill anyone yet
but that that day will come with Laris
and Kristen and Otto Allison is
surrounded by Violent Men she's got
three Devils on her shoulder and no
angel rhaenyra tells Daemon That Fire
cost them both what they love because
Rainier's lover Harwin and daemon's wife
Lana both died in fire fire is
destructive but she says that as
targaryens fire is their nature and they
were made to burn together rhaenyra
proposes marriage to Daemon both as a
political alliance against Allison's
greens and as a fulfillment of their
true desires rhaenyra and Daemon have
both had Loveless marriages of Duty now
they want a marriage of passion and
power of Fire and Blood of uncle and
niece but they can't marry while
rhaenyra is married to Lenor so rhaenyra
and Daemon plan to fake lenor's death
Daemon gets Leno's boyfriend Carl to
Stage a fake fight with Lenor Daemon
murders some guy and they burn the body
so that everyone thinks Carl killed and
burned lanor rhaenyra wants people to
think that she paid Carl to kill lanor
she wants people to think she's a killer
so that as a ruler she'll be feared she
doesn't want to be disrespected as a
weak ruler like her father viserys is
but the truth is that rhaenyra loves
Lenor she appreciates his devotion
earlier so she sets him free lets him
choose love over Duty so Lenor Rose into
the sunset with Carl Lenor shaves his
head to hide his valerion identity to
free himself from the restrictions of
his responsibilities Lenor leaves his
family and leaves his Dragon sea smoke
which would be hard Lenor loves sea
smoke can a dragon rider ever really
separate from their dragon in Game of
Thrones Daenerys tries to separate from
her dragons but that doesn't last the
Dragon Rider bond is deep and is Magic
there are hints in the books that
dragons can sense their Rider's location
so maybe sea smoke will try to find
Lenor but that would reveal to everyone
that Lenor is still alive also as long
as Lenor is alive it might be impossible
for anyone new to bond with sea smoke
and that could also give away that lane
or is alive so as a Valyrian Dragon
Rider can lanor really Escape his
Destiny when Daemon went East he
couldn't stay away lano's Escape is a
change from the books in the books it
seems that Lenor really is killed by
Carl but Fire and Blood is all about
unreliable narrators and historians not
knowing the full truth so hot D can give
us these twists that surprise even
people who've read the books with lane
or gone rhaenyra and Daemon get married
in an ancient Valyrian ritual maybe
Daemon learned about this Ritual from
those Valyrian books in Mentos all
Valyrian sorcery is rooted in blood or
fire so they're surrounded by candles
and where fiery clothes and they draw
blood with dragon glass the special
volcanic rock found on Dragonstone that
can kill White Walkers they draw
Valyrian glyphs on each other that mean
Fire and Blood so this wedding is not
like rhaenyra and daemon's previous
weddings this one is passionate and
Grand with the weight and possibly the
magic of ancient ceremony rhaenyra says
this marriage strengthens Rainier's
claim to the throne because it combines
rhaenyra's claim as viserys's daughter
with daemon's claim as viserys's brother
but this might also turn people against
rhaenyra some people don't want Daemon
anywhere near the throne because he's so
violent and unpredictable and it may be
seen as an insult to the rhaenyra and
Daemon remarried so so soon after Lena
and lenor's apparent deaths King viserys
will be pissed because this Royal
marriage happened without his permission
and the apparent death of Lenor could
weaken rhaenyra's alliance with the
valerions will Corliss and rhaenys think
that rhaenyra killed their son or will
rhaenyra tell them the truth that Lena
was alive like fire this marriage is
powerful but dangerous rhaenyra's actus
as rhaenyra and Daemon are a terrible
match because they're so similar they
have a dangerous chemistry rhaenyra has
wanted this marriage for a long time but
will Daemon be a good husband he doesn't
have a great track record
so as divisions deepen between Allison's
greens and Rainier as blacks both sides
turn to their darkest most dangerous
allies the whole royal family spirals
towards blood and fire if you want to
know the full story of the targaryens
you've got to check out the Game of
Thrones books there's the main series
The World Book duncaned egg and Fire and
Blood which tells the story of Hot D you
can get any one of these on audiobook
for free right now at audible.com ASX
sign up for a Premium Plus trial
membership and you can get an audiobook
to keep even if you canceled the trial
you can get any Game of Thrones book or
Lord of the Rings or Dune membership
also includes unlimited access to
thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
audible plus catalog sign up at
audible.com ASX or text ASX to 500-500
thanks for watching please like And
subscribe and check out the the podcast
feeds linked below thank you to the
patrons including Samia Javed Greg names
call me Catalyst toy button Matthew
Chaya ravalotti classless and Yannick
cheers
am I so out of touch
no it's the children who are wrong